I want you to go back to the time when
you were considering applying to the
Stanford Graduate School of Business the
school located here in the heart of
Silicon Valley surely one of the things
you are considering with the potential
to launch your own business after
graduation well you're not alone in fact
16 percent of graduating MBAs go on to
become entrepreneurs after they graduate
here from Stanford fast forward to where
we are today many of us in this room
myself included were just a few weeks
away from graduating and of course as
you're thinking about your options for
after the GSB there are many things that
you're considering maybe you have a
mountain of student debt that you're
figuring out how can you pay it down or
if you're an international student
perhaps visas or top of mind because you
want to stay here in the u.s.
potentially you even have a job offer
that you're seriously considering but if
you're also like me you have that hard
string inside of you that's gently
pulling and netting at you reminding you
why you came here to Stanford because
you want it to be an entrepreneur the
difference however between you being
able to potentially start your business
or not at all this slide heavily on your
ability to get funding in fact in a
recent survey six out of ten new
entrepreneurs cite funding as one of the
critical issues they say it's one of the
things that keeps them up at night as
we've learned here at the GIC at
business school cash flow is the
lifeblood of any business it can be the
difference between success and failure
it provides me with the opportunity to
hire the right people build your first
prototype launch your first website or
potentially even provide yourself with a
fairest living wage and your ability to
get that funding comes
and your ability to make the pitch I'm
very excited to be sharing with you
something that we've been working on for
quite some time which is how you can do
the art of the pitch now here to tell
you more about our team and why we're
the team to make the pitch again so with
over 25 years of experience in teaching
so now we are the best team here
representing the art of teaching
we are from GFC MBA students and any
citrus so we understand our market which
is the Gypsy student you we are inspired
to be an entrepreneur after graduation
we have been taking stock of Guerra link
lounge has all these entrepreneurial
classes and we have already goes through
this project talking with investor so we
understand how important it is to make
the pitch and how hard it is to get the
funding and also our team is very solid
in the diverse house has been sitting on
the investment board Gabrielle is a
communication group yet myself I have a
terrorist in branding and strategy
Walter ruff has a background in engineer
and most of all we invert the same
culture we have a shear division which
is chaired by change organizations and
change the world so by now you may
already understand how important a key
for the peach whether the investment
they are inventing company not only for
the next big idea but they are looking
for the next base T and how you can
demonstrate your team is the best to
solve this problem during the peach so
first you need to share we have a
coherent vision we have a shared passion
to the pearl
you are soft and sickened we want to
demonstrate the team have a diverse
emitter this we have so many expertise
and industry knowledge third we need to
communicate openly to really make sure
the team has good team dynamic research
shows 65% of stock of a show in the
first year because of the team dynamics
in the last very important we need to
demonstrate the commitment so our genes
oiling for that now you know our team is
the best afford at the beaches and our
like a cow to share with you the journey
of ideas thank you so at a high level we
think of taking an investor through a
pitch as a journey and this is actually
a borrowed concept from leading
strategic communications expert for
Albert there no that's a blend some
credibility to this but we think of the
initial stages first building curiosity
so you want the investors to know what
your business is at that second we want
them to build into an understanding so
not only are they curious about what
your business is but they kind of
understand what your business is about
and finally once they have an
understanding you want them to lead -
you want to lead them up - excitement so
they're excited about your idea they
want to hand you their money so the
question is how do you move your
investor along this path we have three
main piece of advice for you the first
is to convey your idea the second is to
sell the benefit and the third is to
keep in mind that investors are not
customers we'll take these one step at a
time
so first of all convey your idea you
want to accurately portray what the
status quo is and what the problems
people are facing today and how your
business aims to solve these problems so
as an example proper pitch goes credit
cards are a great way to set money but a
horrible way to borrow and prosper solve
this problem by directly from
lenders and consumers secondly you want
to sell the benefits not just the
features so the features are what you
put into your product the benefits is
what consumer arrives from them so as an
example when Steve Jobs first talked
about nine you talked about how when the
features was it create feature and you
as a consumer derive the benefit of
being able to build - or joggin without
worry that you need it and finally
perhaps most importantly you want to
keep in mind that your investors are not
your consumers you spent a lot of time
convincing customers why your products
is the best but for investors they care
more about the sustainability of the
business model underneath and whether or
not you can generate money so to review
the three main ideas we're pitching each
day or one convey your idea to keep in
mind that benefits sell features tell
and three keep in mind that your
investors are not customers so to bring
it all phone please welcome sir Rob so
for a moment let's imagine six months
down the line for the intrapreneurs
amongst us we've already got the base
and we are multiple times gone to the
grind
but eventually is nailed it and we have
ended up with a shower of money ora but
the point here is what did you do in the
last six months which ended up in this
result and if you can look last what we
just did we would not just present you
how to pitch we were actually making you
the idea itself so Gabrielle took us
through the market which is the students
here and the problem which is the desire
or the ability to pitch Karl showed us
want the ideas and how we can
communicate that and Yann told us
these competencies of our team our
camaraderie and our shared values so
these are the three main things that you
would want your investor to walk away
with as you take them on the journey to
excitement they leave the room after
your presentation super excited and with
these three things nailed into their
heads and why is that important because
the investor you are pitching to is only
your primary office but just as
important is your secondary audience
which is their investor sorry because
the investment committee will decide
whether you get the second chance or not
and that depends on how well your
primary investor is able to communicate
your ideas to the investment committee
so to grip on the point you would want
your investor to walk away with three
main topics or points from your pitch
one is the market which is the problem
and the growth potential second is the
team the great competency is the
diversity and the camaraderie and third
is the idea itself and how unique it is
and what benefits it provides so take it
home from here we'll take all questions
from here on thank you so much
[Music]
you